Bởi khoảng 2 giờ 2 mi phút thông nè, mình tạm thằng chiến năm 2018,
nếu không nhìn đang推 trọt tại khu nghe trọt thế khác, phường miếng, tình bắt ninh,
cũng như người dân xí sống gần đó hất lượng nè thể một tính lộn khá gia từ tình bũ ngủ nhạc.
Ngay sâu đó, lửa và khỏi bốc lên giữ dụng các không nhìn khoảng 4 triệu hộ và những trong bảo tin cho lực lượng chức năng.
Nhận được tý báo, phòng cảnh xác phòng trái trứ trái phạc của nạn cứu hộ,
công an tình bắt ninh đã được động người cùng phương tịch tới hình chương, phương cạnh bộ,
chiến xí công an phương miếng hình chương trí khai công tác đuộ và giúp lượng.
Hí tiếp cận được hình chương, lực lượng chức năng đã phát hiện 2 thi tìm.
Nát nhân được xác định là anh khoảng 1 lượng,
sinh năm 2018 và vợ là chỉ lih thiết biết đây,
sinh năm 2018 cũng quế tại sạm đu gì tính bắt ninh.
Đúng biết, vô trong anh lờ đã推 trọt tại đây được khoảng 5 năm.
Theo khoảng 1 tả hình chương, mừng có từ lượng của phòng trọt bị tuổi bây giờ xuất em từ vụ nổ,
tương và trình nhạm khói đen.
Nên phòng xuất hiện nhiều vò loàn và ủng kinh lại có kích thức khác nhau.
Theo lãnh đạo của ngàn phương miếng,
kết quả kinh chá, sắp mình bà đầu đình giá nguyên vụ nổ là gió vợ trong anh lờ từ quân phá nổ trong phòng trọt.
Hình vụ việc đăng đục đu chá làm gió thương quy định.